after hearing their stories about
fighting for the land and reviving
traditional practices there is still one
more question we had about Alaskan
Natives
[Music]
what if you Lea wrong probably almost
everything we're all Eskimos whether we
all live in igloos Alaskan Natives are
just a bunch of drunks and they live off
the system or they just want their
handouts like oh wow you you're so
well-spoken for a native person you know
it's like well yeah the first century of
course I speak English well the biggest
misconception is that is that we're just
one people but we're 20 distinct nations
and there's just a tremendous amount of
diversity among our community it would
be like just for my question nation for
example to the new bag nation of North
it would be almost equivalent to China
and India
that's how different we are in Alaska
you come to all these conclusions that
are erroneous because you don't
understand the history of colonization
in the state of Alaska men that really
contributed to why we're suffering why
we suffered so much why there's
alcoholism and suicide and drug abuse
domestic violence and and why all of
these things are happening we come from
amazing resilient cultures and people
and those things that they see are
really the result of an unjust system we
have huge challenges in front of us in
our generation but I do believe in our
capacity to address those challenges
head-on I feel like I cannot be worn out
and I refuse to be worn out by this
system and
and I let my frustration then fuel my
action when I'm an ancestor way in the
future I think I would want our children
and people to be happy and healthy and
thriving it's really exciting to see
Alaska native people embracing and
feeling good about who we are as
indigenous people we're taking our
ceremonies we're claiming them and
adapting it to our lives now but we're
here we're still here today and we got
to maintain who we are as people while
living in you know this modern world
[Music]